New York soude surveillance sur les rues
le convoi de Donald Trump traverse la
ville pour se rendre au palais de
justice au total 11 voitures pour
escorter l'ancien président des
États-Unis les caméras du monde entier
sont braquées sur cet événement sans
précédent une fois que dans notre
chambre franchit le seuil du palais de
justice il est en état d'arrestation
puis une première apparition lorsqu'il
se rend devant le juge Juan motion au
15e étage on voit Donald Trump l'air un
peu hagard entouré de ses avocats
écouter les 34 chefs d'accusation il
appelait des non coupable c'est sur elle
avait-il écrit un peu plus tôt sur les
réseaux sociaux le procureur de
Manhattan est sans équivoque dans notre
chambre à offrant la loi à 34 reprises
aura duré plus longtemps que prévu selon
la poursuite dans notre chambre a commis
ses crimes pour éviter toute publicité
négative avant les élections de 2016
parmi les accusations l'affaire stommy
dernière ce qui aurait reçu 130 000
dollars pour qu'elle garde le silence
sur leur liaison extraconjugale avant
les élections
inversement qui est passé sous couvert
de frais juridiques et non de frais de
campagne ce qui violerait la loi sur le
financement électoral également
l'affaire Karen McDo une autre liaison
que dans notre champ aurait eu en 2006
la jeune femme aurait également gardé le
silence en échange d'un montant de
150000 dollars remis par le journal de
Nash land Cry montant que Donald Trump
aurait également remboursé pour étouffer
l'affaire
les preuves vont démontrer que c'était
pour dissimuler décrire relié aux
élections de 2016
il est frustré blessé d'y son avocat
mais je vais vous dire une chose il est
motivé et rien ne va l'arrêter
même les plus fervents critiques de
Donald Trump considère ses mises en
accusation trop faibles
vont être rejetés affirme John Bolton
qui prédit qu'il sera quitté
dans notre chambre ne s'adressera pas à
la presse à la sortie du palais de
justice un ancien président encombrant
pour la ville de New York qui avait
mobilisé toute sa force policière en
plus de 35000 policiers en état d'alerte
en cas de débordement soupir de
soulagement des autorités new-yorkaises
lorsque l'avion de Donald Trump décolle
avec un sentiment d'une mission
accomplie jusqu'à la prochaine
comparution le 4 décembre les avocats de
dans notre champ ont jusqu'au 8 août
pour riposter et rejeter les accusations
à Washington le président de la Chambre
des Représentants Keven mokholfee parle
d'ingérence dans un processus
démocratique et que le Congrès va tenir
hassandre responsable d'instrumentaliser
le système judiciaire ici Radio-Canada
New York